Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
A rectangle is divided into four rectangles with the following areas:
The yellow rectangle has an area of 16, the blue rectangle has an area of 13 and the green rectangle has an area of 39.
What is the area of the orange rectangle?
Can you figure it out? Give this problem to try and when you're ready keep watching the video or the solution!
You could solve this problem by setting up variables and then eventually solving for the area of the unknown rectangle.
But there is a geometric principle that will make the problem a lot easier.
First, notice that the green and the blue rectangle share the same height.
This means we can figure out the width of the green rectangle relative to the width of the blue rectangle.
Because the area of the green rectangle is 3 times the area of the blue rectangle,
this means the blue rectangle fits exactly 3 times into the green rectangle.
The green rectangle has the width that is 3 times the blue rectangle.
This means the orange rectangle has the width that is 3 times that of the yellow rectangle.
So the yellow rectangle will fit exactly 3 times into the orange rectangle.
Therefore, the area of the orange rectangle will be 3 times that of 16 which is 48.
Did you figure this out?
Thanks for watching this video please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math and game theory. You can catch me on my blog mindyourdecisions,
which you can follow on Facebook, Google+ and Patreon.
You can catch you on social media @preshtalwalkar. And if you like this video
please check out my books. There are links in the video description.